I think the big problem this country has
is being politically correct and I don't
frankly have time for total political
correctness and to be honest with you
this country doesn't have time either a
majority of Americans are now agreeing
with President Trump that political
correctness it's gone too far
52% now saying they're against the
country becoming more PC and are upset
that there are too many things that
people can't say anymore
should 2020 Democrats pay attention to
this warning sign Greg I say all the
time I think this is one of the reasons
he got elected people are so tired of
not being able to speak their minds
having to bite their tongues it's the
most dangerous time in the world to be a
comedian what do you think I'm alarmed
52% is not a lot yeah in this it's not
enough and I saw it said 30 37 or 38 in
favor so there was some other middle
ground there here's the danger about the
with the concept of political
correctness is that it morphs it's it's
the whole point of it is that it's
constantly changing and progressing over
time it expands like the blob so so what
happens is something that was acceptable
two years ago is not acceptable now so
they dredge up things that you said two
years ago and throw it in your face
what its positions as a safety blanket
but now it's been spread over culture
and it's suffocating real speech the
only solution to this and also if you do
one scary thing about PC that if you
have a if you forgive somebody for doing
something that's considered a violation
of the PC thing you are an accessory to
the racism or sexism or homophobia or
transphobia that has occurred so you
can't even it at PC thinking eliminates
the concept of forgiveness which is how
our civilization is built is on people
making mistakes so the solution here is
why I've said before is people have to
share the risk right comedians writers
artists talk shows when they see
somebody like mica or met you know
whoever it's do something stupid you
don't take out the pitchforks and the
torches you forgive their apology and
you move on because that's the only way
that you're going to reduce the history
on that his stare
Oracle histrionics yeah yes that we now
are paralyzed by companies in fear
companies in fear because somebody's
gonna come after you it's terrible but
it's not just that the challenge is it's
not just fear of what you might say now
it's fear of what you may have ever said
ever yes now you have on Twitter and all
that stuff I actually thought I was
impressed with the numbers just because
when you look it's Republican men women
Democratic men and women all four of
them are coming forth and saying they
feel they can't speak their minds the
way they used to which means at least in
everyone across party lines it's
registering like hey I got a walk on
eggshells right here but I wonder what
the age breakdown is I would love to see
that the crosstab on that because I
imagine that it's people like maybe US
and older it's over 30 okay so there's a
lot of young kids who don't believe in
freedom of speech right that's scary
they don't like that those who they were
more in favor of more PC where Democrats
adults under 30 African Americans and
small cities you're talking about for a
reelection should Democrats think about
that yeah well yeah maybe for this term
this 2020 election but in 2024
Millennials are now the largest voting
group they're surpassing baby boomers
the Generation X is pretty small and
unfortunately you can't tell a joke to a
millennial Arius yeah isn't there a
difference though between cultural
sensitivity and cultural
hypersensitivity but you can be
sensitive without going so far that it's
preposterous
of course I watch up so did the office
now which I love and I say they would
never air that today yeah
again to your point about the evolving
blob it never stops now Trump has served
is a huge shield for a lot of people who
felt stifled they're like he could stand
up and say Pocahontas he could say it I
can say it culture should introduce that
we should be okay with that to me
problem is only the surface of the
speech is only the surface of the
problem it's the institutions that then
institutionalize that so you're K
through 12 public schools and your
colleges in your elite media and your
churches and your movies and your social
media pretty soon now you're litigating
Christmas and the flag and you wondered
how did I get here right and it's been
totally infected on the left one I'll
say 55% of those identified as Democrats
favor more political correctness so your
party saying
we want more of this well but listen for
a second think about it what you see is
the strongest proponents of we're too
politically correct are white men older
white men and it's unbelievable it's
like two-thirds of them say oh this
pallulah correctness is terrible it
stinks
but then you start asking about people
who've been denigrated in the past like
blacks and they say oh no you know we we
don't like it and and not only that it's
so interesting to me seventy percent in
this poll said things are worse in terms
of civility under President Trump that
Trump has now emboldened people to say
whatever they want about whoever they
want but I would say african-americans
should have the ability to black America
should have the ability to be offensive
and and politically incorrect to I mean
ultimately that's the oh that's the way
forward everybody should have the right
to be offensive yes everybody should
have the right to be insulted and to
insult if you did if you take the
opposite tact and say my feelings need
to be protected that's an impossibility
across the board you not everybody can
be protected and you will have these
issues and the divisive nassif everybody
said you can offend me as much as you
want and I can offend you
we're equals we're brothers we should
take dan Crenshaw as example yes right
remember the dan gran shot goes on
Saturday Night Live now they're friends
I guess with people a humid day Vicent
he's trying to help him out when he's in
a tough time and everyone said oh that's
the model that we should follow so let's
just let's do that everyone says that
and then does the opposite or you defend
your team but there's somebody on the
other side then you're getting it but I
think it's progress when we'd stop
bullying and and name-calling demonizing
other people I don't like the leverage
that overly sensitive let me be clear
but I don't think that it's it's good
that we you know back in the 50s you
could say this about a woman and say I'm
talking about language I'm talking about
the silencing language on campus I'm
talking about how it's spreading into a
dangerous place you wrote a book on this
yeah yeah I don't like political
correctness I'm a big free speech
advocate but do I think that for example
you and I talking about gay people is
different in 2018 and it would have been
in 2000 yes great yeah absolutely good
yeah well I would agree under prasad all
right well package thieves mess with the
wrong guy the sparkly surprise that has
porch pirates retreating coming